Mr Speaker the world cup doesn't belong
to FIFA and it doesn't belong to the
host nation it belongs to everyone who
loves football
it's totally unacceptable that during
this tournament gay football fans are
unable to acknowledge who they love and
players have been threatened with
suspension if they show solidarity with
those fans shame on FIFA
[Applause]
Britain faces the lowest growth of Any
oecd Nation over the next two years
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this
country has experienced since 2010 the
third highest growth in the G7
this year the fastest growth in the G7
and
multi-decade lows we're getting on to
deliver more growth Mr Speaker we're
delivering freeports we're investing in
apprenticeships we're protecting r d
and if the labor party is serious about
actually supporting growth maybe they
should get on the phone with their union
pay masters and tell them
Mr Speaker
we want to get through premises
questions and you're not helping me okay
he's in total denial we're bottom of the
38 oecd countries who are all in the
same boat when it comes to covert and
Ukraine and he wants a pat on the back
it's like a football manager bottom of
the league at Christmas celebrating an
away draw three months ago and it won't
wash so let's they don't like their
record that's the problem so let's try
it another way why is Britain set to be
the first country into recession and the
last country Out
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I'm pleased that the right
normal gentleman brought up the oecd
report because it contained actually
three very important points firstly it
made the point that actually in the
Years following the pandemic we're
projected to have almost the highest
growth amongst our peer countries
so
it's the point it was crystal clear that
the challenges we Face are completely
International in nature
ugly
Mr Speaker it supported our fiscal plan
because it's credible and ensures
sustainability now the right honorable
gentleman would have known all of that
if he actually read the whole report
but he's not he's not he's not
interested in substance he's an
opportunist Mr Speaker
in in four weeks Mr Speaker in in four
in four weeks in four weeks I've in four
weeks I've strengthened the economy
we've put more money into the NHS and
schools we've delivered a deal we've
delivered a deal to tackle illegal
migration in the same four weeks in the
same four weeks all week
prime minister when I stung you build a
suit though but can I just say to you
you came to me quite rightly and said to
me we want to get through Primus
questions I'm going to give short
answers please stick to it
well Mr Speaker there's only there's
only one party that's crashed the
economy and they're sitting there
and I noticed this Mr Speaker I noticed
this he won't say why Britain is set to
be the first into a recession and the
last out so I will 12 years of Tory
failure followed by 12 weeks of time
Glory chaos for a decade they've let our
economy drift aimlessly before suddenly
cutting the parachute ropes and slamming
it to the ground and because of the
changes he's made a typical household
will end up with taxi increases of 1400
pounds they don't want to hear about
these tax increases of 1400
[Music]
[Applause]
a pound contrast that to a super wealthy
non-dom living here but holding their
income overseas
how much more or order
you're still
I don't need any more I don't need
shouting don't need pointing you meant
to be a good example when it sits on
this front bench because you're on the
second don't suppose what you're meant
to do Mr Speaker I don't think I want to
hear this because of the changes
because of the changes he's made a
typical household will end up paying tax
increases of 1400 pounds
contrast that to a super wealthy non-dom
living here but holding their income
overseas how much more has he asked them
to pay
or just order as I said to the Prime
Minister I said to lead in the
opposition I've got to get through this
list I need you both to help me and
think of other members come on well
Mr Speaker labor had 13 years to address
this issue and do nothing nothing it was
the conservative government that took
action and tightened the rules but the
problem the problem with his idea the
problem with his idea is that it would
end up costing Britain money
not not not my words not my words the
words of the former labor Shadow
Chancellor
oh
right rather than peddling fairy tales
and gesture politics let's actually tell
him what we're doing to deliver for this
country a record increase in the
National living wage protecting Millions
from energy bills protecting the
pensioners triple lock that's what we're
doing for this country
Mr speaker thank you called me at the
same rate of the last Labor government
we'd have tens of billions pounds more
oh Mr Speaker it wasn't a trick question
the answer is he's not asked non-doms to
pay a penny more every year he talks
about the money every year that's 3.6
billion pounds thrown away because he
won't make them pay their pay their
taxes here how many extra doctors could
Britain afford with that money
for Mr Speaker I'm pleased that he
brought up doctors because last week we
delivered record increases in funding
for the NHS
not just more doctors but more nurses
more scans more operations that shows
our commitment to prioritize the NHS not
my words the words of the NHS chief
executive
scrapping the non-dom status would allow
us to train 15 000 doctors every year
that's what labor would do
and we can carry on handing out tax
breaks to the super rich
or we can live in a society where people
don't have to go private to get a
doctor's appointment
[Applause]
[Music]
also hands sell 90p for every one pound
they spend drilling so they haven't paid
a penny in Windfall tax
Mr Speaker you may have seen this week
that somebody shredded ten thousand
pounds in protest at those propping up
an oil and gas giant but he shreds ten
thousand pounds every other minute
propping them up which does he think is
the more absurd
[Music]
Mr Speaker this is the government that
has actually put in place an economic
plan that will develop deliver
confidence and stability to our economy
and all I've heard from the olive gen
today there's there's no answers there's
no substance because there's no plan Mr
Speaker
[Applause]
he talks about the NHS we're delivering
record funding for the NHS but we can
only do that on the foundations of a
strong economy you can't deliver for the
NHS unless you have a plan for the
economy and he doesn't have either Mr
Speaker uh Mr Speaker every time he
opens his mouth another powerful
business voice says he hasn't got a plan
on growth
the failure of the last 12 years and the
chaos of the last 12 weeks are
compounded by the decisions he's taking
now he won't follow Labor's plan to
scrap non-dom status instead we've got
an NHS Staffing crisis he won't follow
Labor's plan to make oil and gas giants
pay their fair share instead he hammers
working people
and he won't push through planning
reform instead he kills off the dream of
home ownership
too weak to take on his party too weak
to take on vested interest 12 long years
of Tory government five Prime Ministers
seven chancellors why do they always
clobber working people
no
[Applause]
Mr Speaker he talks about leadership
this summer I stood on my principles and
told the country what they needed to
hear even though it was difficult when
he ran for leader he told his party what
they wanted to hear
even now even now he says one thing and
he does the other he says he cares for
working people but he won't stand up to
the unions
he said he he said he'd on a brexit but
he tried to have a second referendum and
and he tries to talk tough about
immigration but he promised to defend
free movement
you can trust him you can trust him to
deliver for his party you can trust me
to deliver for the country
[Applause]